30 seconds did you ever think you would
make it I feel I'm so I a tast sweet
victory I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giv values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we G no value to haters run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the
[Music]
one okay Home Team episode
358 lots of crazy stories and internal
fight going on here that nobody knows
about but I'm going to leak it to you
here in a minute um obviously the top
issue that everybody is wondering what
is really going to happen with Iran and
us the three troops killed by the Drone
strike will react to that there's a lot
of different angles there's some that
are saying we got to attack tan
immediately there are some that are
saying we got to hold up and not do
anything because we're going to go into
war who's right who's wrong who's
contradicting who one side is saying we
shouldn't do it or else the other side
is saying why were you celebrating when
we attacked Assam solmani and you got
said that's the right thing to do so
what are we going to be doing here we'll
process that here together and I'm sure
we have different positions and we'll
process it together outside from that
the lady who is getting the $83 million
Rachel mat if you haven't seen this clip
reacted and asked her so what are you
going to do with the money you're going
to make and honestly the reaction
doesn't make any sense when you see this
video it almost looks like it's out of a
movie sincerely it doesn't look real and
quite frankly it doesn't look good for
the side that's celebrating this it's
the most shallow way to celebrate uh a
number like that but we'll get into that
on when that money is going to come out
one topic that I want to talk about as a
parent is the this issue with AI nudes
the fact that Taylor Swift is not happy
with the AI Nudes on X to the point
where even uh uh Elon Musk is kind of a
blocked some of those pictures that are
going out the news that are being posted
out there are there laws I looked into
it yesterday to see what states have
laws do we have a federal law against AI
nudes you know how does it work out what
are some of the numbers it's happening
more and more to kids should it be a
crime should it be a felony how should
it be treated should people go to jail
what if the person's under raiseed these
are a lot of good questions to ask
obviously we're not lawmakers it's
purely a discussion that we're having
but it's a discussion that a lot of
parents are asking about workers are
paying to get their paychecks early and
PayDay lending on steroids deeply
concerning another one of those things
which is like the buy now pay later
we'll cover that um uh uh what else can
I tell you buy giving chilling nuclear
warning over attacking Iran after
kamakazi drone kills troops some say
that's strong some say that's a
concerning we're going into war again
with Iran uh some say we're already in
war with Iran we'll talk about the Texas
border first kind of a uh uh first of
its kind campaign uh this is according
to NBC News fundraiser was done is being
done in the works between Bill Clinton
Barack Obama Biden combined together so
they're really putting the super team
together
uh uh uh it's super team together to
make sure Trump doesn't win but it's
Clinton Obama and Biden teaming up and
on top of that news in South Carolina
lobbying for uh Biden and then Trump's
team reached out to RFK apparently this
is a New York Post story about
considering him for VP and the fact that
they wouldn't write it off and then some
part of the camp are saying no it's not
really true we never did that so we'll
see what's going on there Snoop Dog
comes out and Praises a very we we weird
candidate which is weird snoop Snoop Dog
straight out of comp you know what he
says right now he said Donald
Trump he's got nothing but love and
respect for Donald Trump now you've seen
the roast cuz Snoop was a part of the
roast 100% it ain't the first time you
kick a black man out of his house
remember when he said that Snoop yeah
snoopa Loop so we'll see what's going on
Steve Harvey had some things to say
about Trump as well uh 15 facts about
een Carroll's case the media doesn't
want you to know about we'll see what
those 15 facts are a man pretending to
be a trans woman raped a female prisoner
at Rikers lawsuit says surprising
obviously another Mega donor uh pauses
donations to Nikki Haley uh unless a
path to Victory is seen big Pharma is at
a Crossroads as J&J MC and others
prepare to lose heaps of revenue from
Blockbuster drugs by the way it's not a
couple billion dollars it's a lot of
money when you hear what's going to
happen here somebody's writing a memoir
that some of you guys may want to order
on Amazon you can pre-order it if you
wanted I don't think you're able to
pre-order it but jaline Maxwell is
writing a memoir in prison to combat
misinformation how sweet is that want to
do that what what a sweetheart right
what a nice demon you know I mean we'll
see what's going to happen there Super
Bowl quarterback you ready Brock pie
made 870 this season this stat is crazy
16 college football players made more
money than the starting back that's
taking the team to the Super Bowl yeah
okay and we'll we'll cover some of those
stats some of you guys listening to this
make more money than Brock pie okay
which uh uh it's we respect made more
money on manck last month Brock by the
way maybe actually if you break it down
in the month yeah you may have made
thank you everybody more money than
Brock birdie chilling AI predicts eight
events that could trigger World War II
and kill Millions obviously a very
inspirational story AI in there too
falling inflation Rising in growth give
us the world's best recovery wo says
we'll cover that and then M musk hires a
100 uh uh content moderators in Austin
uh uh by the end of the year obviously a
lot of this has to do with fighting off
you know different things that's going
on and uh advertisers Jamie Diamond said
a few things about the economy there
just a lot of things that we want to
talk about to hopefully we'll get
through all of them and Nancy Pelosi was
pissed off at some of the people that
are you know saying certain things
ludicrous dedicated a song to Nikki
Haley you oh yeah it's it's favorite
song move you know that's my
neighbor Vinnie who Luda lud's your
neighbor Liv two doors down with his mom
I swear I worked out with him and his
two kids the other day Cadillac does he
have like Cadillac grill this is
Cadillac Grills Cadillac AR Cod he's the
AR Cod you you mentioned Elon mus you
know the neuralink yesterday was the
first somebody tried it for somebody's
in somebody's hooked up to the machine
well maybe we'll talk to you if you're
open to the idea that we send it like a
project and we record what happens to
you next thing you know 99% of stories
you do for Value tment I would for for
us I would get nuring you would do
nuring yeah speak Spanish French you
wouldn't take one of those did you see
what Joy Reed said on a hot mic did you
actually hear that love I love it okay
it's the point okay well we hot
R can you stand over there just go
please Wedding Crashers if you guys are
those we should do a little Russia and
China rush to defend Ally Iran as us
prepares response okay all right so God
willing we'll get through half of these
stories but there's a lot of things
going on uh one thing I do want to tell
you guys something very weird happened
last night so there's this war going on
with inv vment I typically we don't want
to leak Wars because you know it's
controversy and issues and people don't
need to know the real truth about
internal Wars that's going on Joy we
just talking about us but yeah but
there's a war going on between a
Canadian and and a Israeli Jew okay
American American Jew proud American
potato potato whatever and the the war
is we've never had a person with a th000
mans okay ever that's never happened Rob
it's so bad right now with man between
Adam and and uh uh Tom this is where
they're at okay uh Tom is at 937 Ms Adam
is at 964 Adam last week quietly lowers
his man to 10 bucks we know that's steel
it's a total steel well I announced it
on saska I as a birthday totally get it
and I love it I love it and happy early
birthday to you so what does Tom do Tom
takes the lead and goes to also 10 bucks
Tom's at 9 Tom you went down to 10 as
well can I say these numbers Tom is at
937 man Adam's at 964 one of them will
be the first 2,000 but here's what Tom
said what Tom in his profile Rob is
there any way you can find you can do it
on the website if you go to man and you
look at Tom's profile here's what Tom
said I'm going to send you the
screenshot Tom do now no you just have
to see what he puts there Rob if you
just show this clip here I had no idea
Tom is Canadian for those of you for
those of you that have been manting you
can't find it there but Rob I just send
this picture to you show this to the
audience I think it's important for
people to see what's going on here by
the way man is about to cross 200,000
downloads it's on fire no joke it's on
fire what's going on with man a bunch of
people doing man for last week we had
500 I think 70 people that bought a man
individually 570 different people yeah
that bottom man individually with others
pull up this uh Tom's profile right now
if you can show this guys in the back
who look what Tom says he says if I beat
Adam 2,000 Vinnie gets $500 wait a
minute by the way that's for shoes to go
with the suit that you beat us all in
one now wait a minute I was not
consulted no constituents were you're
going to get 500 bucks is that binding
Tom it is binding I will pull out five C
notes and hand them to you here so you
can get fabulous shoes shoes with your
okay can I can I say one thing though
like I'm at seven where am I 700 and
something you know what Tom just said
Tom said ever since we announced the 500
he's done more than you have done yeah
can I can I say something to my consist
734 hey guys we're not out it's not just
a race between them if I get to a I can
win this damn thing too can hey Manors
let's come on what's what's your price
right now you're at 20 bucks I'm
dropping it right now I can help your
business I can help your startup I can
help your financing I can help you a lot
of
ways to do drugs I can help Vinnie I
have I Vinnie so you're a charity case
now apparently according to to no I
wasn't did he even let you know that
this was the thing I wasn't I wasn't are
you guys working in cahoots or just do
when is your birthday when is your
birthday feary check this out my
birthday this weekend let me say this by
the way big party this weekend let me
say this as well we'll talk about that
so let me say this to you if you're a
supporter of Adam okay if you're not a
supporter of Adam if some of you guys
maned everybody and you told everybody
you're a supporter of them okay you're
like supporting everybody no Adam's
birthday's coming up man with them wish
my happy birthday and have a
conversation with them and you're doing
a bunch of calls bunch of calls are
setting up UT calls and Tom's doing a
bunch of 50-minute calls on Saturdays
anyways can I say one more thing 20
seconds before we go into a story I
appreciate you buddy your family out
apparently you haven't seen your family
in weeks all you've been doing is doing
man wow Tom like you're a family man
you're a Christian you're a good man I
didn't realize you're Canadian I'm an
American born in America you're born
Canada I didn't realize that you're that
you're a trau fan but your family misses
you Tom we not I get that you've lowered
your prices you're you're literally
treating B like a charity kid okay so if
you want
to meeting where we you guys decide who
you want to get to let's go into the
stories all right let's go into the
stories
um Taylor Swift okay I want to start off
with the first Story Taylor Swift
searches apparently blocked by X
following AI news and this is a story
that a lot of people are concerned about
she's even thinking about suing so
Twitter X blocked search results for
Taylor Swift and related terms like
Taylor Swift nude and Taylor Swift AI
after pornographic AI generated images
of the singer flooded the platform
benign search still yields results the
White House has expressed concern over
the proliferation of these images urging
Congress to consider legislative action
pressre secretary Karen jeaner
emphasized the need for social media
companies to enforce their rules against
the spread of misinformation and
non-consensual explicit imagery New York
Congressman Joe moral is using the Swift
image incident to advocate for a bill
that would criminalize the
non-consensual search sharing of digital
alter explicit images while social soci
media platforms attempted to remove the
original image the new fake image
surface potentially complicating
enforcement efforts Rob is there any
other the pictures that's not new that
we can show like is there is there
anything you can't show yes maybe show
the one with her and Trump that you
showed us yesterday is that nude or is
that not nude not n not nude so can we
show that or no yes all right let's see
this one here that you got so before we
go to the back uh uh uh okay first of
all Tom I'll come to you until Rob finds
it Tom what's your reaction like look at
that one right there okay that's a great
couple that they look happy look at that
picture right there can you zoom in a
little bit so we can see that is that
the same people that are doing it that's
a winning campaign right there now why
is everybody in the back Indian that's
my concern but the guy that made maybe
that's like Awards in India so what what
are your thoughts on this with these AI
news that taking place and by the way
you have two daughters this is this is
happening to a lot of girls in high
schools Tom thoughts well the the first
element is yeah we're talking about
Taylor Swift and Trump and all these
things like this haha and and oh now you
know is X and other people going to
censor what do you do the social medias
are going to have to have you know
enforcement response groups when law
enforcement comes out and says hey this
person is a is a victim of cyber
bullying these these images are fakes
they're going to have to uh the burden's
going to be on Facebook it's going to be
on X and it's going to be on Insta when
law enforcement comes down and says we
have active cyber bullying case here
this has to come down it's not just
going to be about and by the way it can
influence political campaigns it could
influence you know celebrities it's you
know picture like this this is ludicrous
we know that not ludicrous rapper but
it's like ridiculous and we all know
that that's not real it looks real it's
incredible Photoshop but it is not real
but you're going to have to have um
response the social media companies are
going to have to respond because law
enforcement are going to come down one
day with things like like this and
you're going to we already have girls
that are subject to cyber bullying that
commit suicide and you know there's
there's a big big thing here with the
quality of the deep fixes yeah this is
the new reality we just saw that the
world economic for and Davos what they
list as their top concern for the world
after 2024 misinformation or
disformation there's a couple other
points yes we just saw what happened in
the shakeup with chat GPT and Sam Alman
the ins and outs and the whatever and
all the confusion and the chaos that was
happening in the AI world what's
happening is not going to stop because
Photoshop this is not new this is not
some new anomaly AI has just made
photoshop on steroids basically more
prevalent out there but we're going to
see this time and time again in 2024
during the time of the election we're
going to see Trump and and Obama making
out we're going to see Biden doing all
stuff with like anything you could
possibly think of is going to be out
there and you're never going to tell the
difference by the way I'm with you but
the question is here's a question it's a
real question should it be should it be
illegal should people go to jail for it
should people get a MISD demean or a
felony for it should people be fine for
it how should kids under the age of 18
who are very good at doing this how
should they be treated a lot of people
that are making deep fakes live in
another country they don't live by the
laws that you live by so what are you
gonna do to me if the guy lives in India
it's like I don't care come try to
arrest me you can't do nothing to me I'm
going to do all of this as much as I can
there's so many different things to it
and I have my thoughts towards this but
but I want to know how you guys feel
about it Vinnie yourself well uh well
first my thing is let's go back to who
cuz again I'm I'm always taking the step
back like you say fou the money Adam
who's this this AI stuff this fake deep
I've been seeing a bunch of them Trump
you know a year ago it's Taylor Swift
and think about this she's going to be
used to manufacture consent of the
regulation of AI technology because uh
which is redefined by the Obama Obama
just met with Biden about this type of
situation notice how they're using her
to be like oh by the way that's
America's sweetheart you can't show her
so uh if Congress decides to take
legislative action over the AI images
which they're doing bro they you can't
even search her right now on X or
anything for for the for those images
the the bad ones Karine Jean Pierre said
we can expect lawmakers to smuggle
that's not a good word smuggle in
provision to regulate social media
possibly with loopholes that will enable
politicians to censor political content
so they're going to use her and be like
oh we can't not Taylor Swift and then
once this legislation come out comes out
P they're going to put in there they're
trying to control what Nikki Hy was
talking about the algorithm they got to
stop this algorithm of fake stories and
fake BS and dude what perp because and
we're going to get into how much they're
using Taylor Swift this year is going to
be one of the most Rob can you pull up
what I just sent you here so this is an
article I want to read to you guys I
want to see purely regulation wise
students are sharing AI generated fakes
of nudes of classmates and there's no US
federal law to stop them okay this is
just a month and a half ago two months
ago go down Rob the two and a half
months ago go down a little bit more to
the stats if you can go go go go go
right there right there and then we'll
go to the state zoom in a little bit and
I'll read this so here we go this is
stats 290% how much fake news have
ballooned since 2018 on the top 10
websites that host AI generated porn
photos the waer reported citing industry
analyst
Genevie o 290 okay 143,000 AI generated
porn videos added in 2023 across the 40
most popular website for fake videos a
figure that surpasses all new such
videos from 2016 to 2022 that more more
in one year than seven years combined
4.2 billion views is what it generated
52% increase in deep fakes pornographic
videos uploaded to websites 90 to 95%
share of deep fake videos are
non-consensual porn involving women
according to Sensi sensity AI a company
that has tracked online deep fake videos
on December 18 26,800 us victims of
sextortion campaigns that this year
through September according to FBI
that's 149% increase compared to 2019
and then these are the laws with States
okay non-exhaust and list of US states
were Distributing generated n nud as a
crime California the golden state has
allowed people to sue Anyone who puts
their image in a pornographic deep fake
video under proposed legislation the
creation intentional distribution and
exhibition of pornographic deep fakes
would be criminalized that's California
Virginia Virginia you got it right under
its revenge porn law which bans
spreading nude images of video with the
intent to coers harass or intimidate
another person Virginia covers deep
fakes breaking the law could be result
in a 12-month prison sentence damn and
$2,500 in fines Minnesota a new law
enacted in July makes it a crime to use
deep fakes to influence an election or
to diss disseminate sexual Imes without
the subject consent punishment 3 years
in prison $5,000 on fine and and I'll
read the last one and come to you New
York the state last month officially
made it illegal to disseminate AI
generated explicit images or deep fakes
of a person without their consent
resulting in a year in jail and $1,000
in fine interesting Adam so you we're
talking about government stepping in and
basically doing something about so
there's nothing Federal right now
there's only state but what we know
about government is they are not moving
fast they are moving slow who moves fast
is Tech big Tech so you hear that the
new um the Microsoft CEO South dandel
says we need to move fast on this the
problem with government the problem with
Congress is a they're dysfunctional as
hell what the hell are they going to do
and if they do anything it's going to
take 6 12 24 months plus there's an
election there's going to be all sorts
of Shifting going on there Tech needs to
step up and do this chat gbt open AI
needs to step up and do this this is on
them because Congress is going to move
way too slow on this Tech is moving 100
mes hour Congress is moving 2 m hour
plus you ever seen Congress try to
debate crypto and crypto is have no idea
what they're talking well you know when
uh Bitcoin and the blockchain and the
bit like they have no clue Mitch
McConnell's giving a speech on
blockchain yeah zero clue big Tech is
the people that need to be responsible
for this government is going to move way
too slow they have no clue what's going
on they're going to drop the ball
complet and this is the early stages you
guys realize what's going to happen in
in 5 years you're not going to be able
people are going to be going to court to
try to prove like that is not me imagine
in 5 years what this is going to be
there's going to be videos and they
going by the time you disseminate oh
that's not Trump doing XYZ people
already made up their minds you know
what I mean so Adam brings up something
about um Tech so let's just let's just
follow this really quick all you have to
do is follow the money and we'll take
the easy one internationally created
porn videos of celebrities there's all
sorts of sites out there we've read
about all of them that say oh I've got
the early porn video that you know some
Starlet did when she was only 18 and you
know it's BS so as long as there's
demand for people around the world to
see that porn for 10 bucks or whatever
they pay then there are there's going to
be International Deep fakes of
celebrities trying to make a buck on it
so there big business now in the US when
the states make it a penalty the tech
has to respond and Adam's got a point
here Tech is going to get subpoena so
when the state of California subpoena
Tech to say Hey you have to take this
stuff down we've got an open case here
Tech is going to have to take it down
and it guess what it doesn't matter
whether it's fake or not Tech will take
it down because your daughter will be in
something and by the way these laws here
are for revenge porn and deep fakes so
if your daughter whether it's real or
not or your son whether it's real or not
is being circulated you go to law
enforcement law enforcement says
Facebook take it down they're going to
have to have all the systems in place to
go find it identify it and take it down
and they've got facial recognition they
have a lot of things they can work with
and tools so Tech is going to have to
build a whole library of tools to push a
button and take it down but the the
deterrent to distribute anything is
what's important and you saw Minnesota
and Virginia actually have really strong
laws now for any revenge porn deep fake
or not and that's where the deterrent
has to come from somebody bullying your
kid they get hit the biggest concern
that I would have is we all remember a
time when there was actually real stuff
that was put out there Kim Kardashian
she became famous for a sex tape Paris
Hilton um Hulk Hogan was part of The
Gawker whatever that was going on with
that Pamela Anderson that was probably
the most famous leak sex tape of all
time the difference is that was actually
real this is all fake yeah none of this
is real as much as we want to see Taylor
Swift sitting at Trump's lab having fun
it's not real you know how Trump put out
the fake news fake news this is all
fake you know what this does to me is a
part of it like if you're trying to hurt
elections yeah that's a concern but to
me a part of this this is not going to
go away correct I'm telling you because
how you going to hold somebody have you
guys seen this recent movie that came
out beekeepers have you guys seen be did
you see it yeah what' you think about it
I think it was I'm not a Jason STM fan
but it's uh of it the premise that the
woman killed herself because of what
happened with them right I think that is
the real concern that we're going to get
into the fear of them using you holding
you Hostage to destroy your life and
steal money from you that's a crime y
all this other stuff it's like okay so
what are you going to do with Babylon B
their stories are fake it's a satire
it's intentionally fake is that now
going to be a crime so to me it's a
slippery slope on what happens here it's
like the moment you get out there you're
gonna be like well I don't want people
to write negative things about me well
then don't be a celebrity they won't
write anything about you part of being a
celebrity is people going to say bad
things about you by the way the next
story I want to get into is this whole
thing with big Pharma being at
Crossroads and J&J MK and others are
preparing to lose billions of dollars
but before we get into this story let's
go to our sponsors first go ahead Rob so
look I've been in the financial industry
since 911 the day before 9/11 and I've
owned stocks bonds mutual funds real
estate crypto gold you name it I've
owned it but the one thing that's very
important part of my portfolio all these
years is gold I love having a percentage
of my network in Gold that I have access
to in case of many different things
that's why we chose to work with our new
sponsor American Harford gold if you
have retirement funds that you cannot
afford to lose American Harford gold
will ship physical gold or silver
directly to your door also if you have
retirement funds that you can't afford
to lose now is the time to call American
Harford gold a precious metal dealer you
can trust they have the finest products
amazing customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on the link in the
description or call 866939 6984 again
6984 okay so big Pharma at a crossroad
as J&J Johnson Johnson murk and others
prepare to lose heap of revenue from
Blockbuster drugs CNBC story so these
companies including Bristol Myers quid
MC Johnson and Johnson face a
significant threat to their revenue as
Blockbuster drug face patent expirations
ready with an estimated $180 billion in
sales at risk for the top 20 big Pharma
companies between now and 2028 according
to ey estimates these patent Cliffs are
concern for pharmaceutical firms
requiring them to find new drugs to
sustain and grow sales the impact varies
depending on the drugs contribution to
total sales and some drugs may also be
subject to Medicare drug price
negotiations further threatening
revenues companies like MC Bristol Myers
and others are strategically addressing
these challenges through Acquisitions
pipeline development and patent
extensions that last one is the tricky
one because that's why they need
lobbyist Tom thoughts on the story you
absolutely found the most important two
words in the story patent extensions who
covered this
CNBC this story is part of CNBC has been
out there practically as a lobbyist for
these because they're talking about risk
to long-term stock price and CNBC is
talking about this oh longterm valuation
play is this a long-term value are they
going to be this that's what's going on
here Pharma companies are out there
lobbying for these stories to be out
there in the business media because they
are out there trying to lobby for patent
extensions and they're doing it they're
doing it and I I I looked up last night
I was trying to find out where the
lobbying for patent extensions has been
in the current election cycle cuz I
wanted to find Senators that were taking
money from certain pharmas specifically
on patent extensions I was trying to
connect those dots I couldn't find
anything quickly last night but ladies
and gentlemen those are the kind of dots
to connect this is how how it works and
also I I found a small small clip that
there's there was leverage being used
with and look at what happened to Disney
with Mickey Mouse they just recently had
a um remember Steamboat Willie or
whatever the film was that you know it's
it could happen to all of us and we work
so hard to build these things and that
belongs to us and you know it was our
drug and we invented it how would you
like it if you invented a lawn mower and
they came away and took away your
ability to make money that is exactly
the arguments being made here never mind
you have to go to the front end of this
and you look at the gouging and the cost
that's on these things and you look at
the ridiculous profits the excessive
profits I'm a capitalist I'm saying
excessive profits the big Pharma foists
on all of us so crime a river big Pharma
this is this has been the law you know
it what it is this hasn't been sprung on
anybody after so many years drugs go
generic those drugs are available at
lower costs for Medicare recipients and
other people and that's the way it works
but they're out there working with CNBC
and others to Lobby in their favor what
a surprise and for patent extensions
what's the what's the biggest drug like
did they list uh what what what are the
drugs I mean this is good news for the
people right so people are the people
that are spending a a crap load of money
on drugs at least they're going to get
what a discount coming up in the in
these upcoming years what are they uh
Merc uh treatments melanon head neck
lung and all that type of stuff uh Myers
blood blood thinners dude that looks
like stuff that people need
bro sh yeah eloquest is an important
blood thinner if you've ever heard you
know my dad's taking this drug and he
can't have broccoli or vitamin K since
his heart attack that's eloquest and it
actually prevents Strokes after heart
attacks it's a good drug now that good
drug it's when I say it's a good drug
it's a proven long-term drug it works
now that will maybe be in generic at a
lot less lot less expensive great for
the God and and God bless them and God
pray for them the people that have
cancer and stuff they're still selling
it guys they're still selling it it's
just now they have to compete with
generic good the the the challenge with
this industry big Pharma is the way CNBC
is talking
CNBC knows this article could have been
changed in a different way here's how
this article could have been written big
farmers at Crossroads as J&J murk and
others are preparing heap of Revenue uh
from Blockbuster drug deal right it
could have said CNBC is deeply concerned
as big Pharma could potentially lose
$180 billion of which they'll use 10% in
advertisement for mainstream media
companies that's the real article that
should have been written right not the
way it's written right now because that
money these big pharmaceutical companies
have to flow through them so you know
who's most concerned with this the big
mainstream media companies are sitting
around saying guys we got to help these
guys of course this can't continue so
the way they win is changing the patent
laws a senator and I think Congressman
can you text Brandon about the senator
and Congressman that lowered the patent
law to 14 years about 30 years ago
they're like 20 years is a very long
time cuz guess what as a whatever the
company is you come out with a new drug
and you you're the one that the patent
on it go make a bunch of money you got 5
years you got seven years you got 10
years so they increased it to 20 years
these guys are like dude that's not fair
let's lower it to 14 years they lowered
it to 14 years for a few years and and
then what happened immediately less than
10 years later they brought it back up
to 20 years and by the way in many
instances these pharmaceutical companies
they hired the right lawyers and
lobbyists and they come in and they're
able to get an additional 18-year
extension on top that's the one on top
can you zoom in a little bit is this
1980 what year is this
uh yeah so the name for its leite
sponsors are Senator uh Patrick Lehi
Democrat okay see where he's at and a
representative Lamar Smith Republican so
you got one that is from Texas the other
one that's from where Vermont yes I
think it's Vermont these guys decreased
it I want to say from 20 years to 14
years and then later on they increased
it back to 20 years and now they're
adding extensions to it this is very
very scary for these guys at their board
meeting but this is very very good for
consumers who can't afford some of these
drugs well I remember when you did the
town hall with vac you this is something
you've been following for quite some
time now what's going on with the
lobbying issue and everything that's
going on with big Pharma uh look we all
see what's going on at the border the
only thing that's more complicated than
the border is Healthcare in America
these days and obviously big farm is a
major extension of that but when you ask
asked VC that question you you actually
showed a image during the town hall you
did with him a couple months ago and you
asked about like the 10-year drop off
that was that whole situation what do
you recall what what thec responded to
that with which one that question that
you asked him about the patent pending
and everything that to VC are you trying
to make a point or you no I'm asking you
what you you're the one that interviewed
VC I I think the way he put it you his
business model on how he build this
company sometimes he would buy things
out of patent and time it well or things
that maybe didn't get approved it's a
very complex situation on how you know
he built his business what he did but
there's a part of it I don't remember
exactly what he said but there's a part
of it where I understand recognizing the
company that created it you ought to get
credit for that and the credit should be
you should have a monopoly on the drug
for a number of years because if it
wasn't for you we wouldn't have the
strug cor go for it but then the
question becomes is that 5 years is that
seven years is that 10 years is at 20
years what is it my idea would be at
first you can have it for five or seven
years then you can give it to
competitors and you lower it by a
certain percentage your price point and
then after a number of years it's
released to public it's generic anybody
else can sell it for whatever price
point I remember the image that you
showed there was a steep drop off after
year 10 I to say massive there was like
a hundred bucks and then it went down to
like two bucks after 10 years Rob do you
have any of those the the drugs that
lose price after patn expire buyers if
you just type that up a bunch will come
up by the way the the the number on how
much they lose in in some cases is 95%
oh my God 95% on how much they lose
value once a pharmaceutical company The
Cliff it's called the patent Cliff yeah
the patent cliff on drugs is massive so
here's your margins whatever you got a
year after the patent expires 51% 2
years 57% 3 years 66% look what happens
after sixth year the drug is 77% cheaper
okay in some cases 95% cheaper and by
the way we're talking about you sell a
drug for
$1,000 95% is what 50 bucks wow it's a
big difference in some of these prices
but you know there's a drug that you pay
annually $3.2
million what is Rob can you Google most
expensive uh drugs in America wasn't it
one of them the guy what was that guy
Martin Martin scrr right at this is it
for cancer p no look at this henics $3.5
million per one time dose what per one
time dose it's $35 million for
hemophilia well one time though
interesting One Time
One the most expensive drug these are
the most expensive drugs2 million okay
for muscle Dy muscular muscle distopy
okay third one sky Sona $3 million per
one time I can't even cereal adrenal
locy yeah wow wow that was intense my
head hurt next one zento $2.8
million and now who who's affording this
what is Happ rich people that are that
you never hear about the average person
is dead those first few there are also
life changes if you take a look at those
that that's not like allergies no those
are onetime or two time doses that are
if it works for that patient that's
major life change or a life extension oh
yeah well I obviously if you're paying
$3 million it's not like of for kids
years old with terrible terrible genetic
you're suffering forever unless you
could spend $3.2 million for one dose oh
my God yeah this is the patent Cliff
that that we were talking about look at
this patent Cliff Vinnie how it works
International look at the drop and then
us look at the drop by the way one of
them went from 1.2 12 billion in 2007
okay look at that year 2006 and it drops
all the way down to what nothing zero oh
my God nothing like it's it's the the
amount of margins for it it becomes
small so the it's really a patent issue
problem they're having in this industry
and if we if any president or politician
wants to really address this there's the
one thing no one wants to talk about and
it's the patent law that's where all
this starts if you touch that great if
you don't it's going to continue
happening because they can do it next um
so this next story is kind of
interesting so the Trump Carol judge was
mentor to een lawyer conflict of
interest appeal expected I'll read this
to you and I'm going to show you a clip
which is kind of weird on how this lady
reacts and how Rachel madow celebrates
which I understand her being happy
because you know Rachel mat is not the
biggest fan
of uh uh Trump but the reaction is
slightly concerning so uh uh here's a
relationship between her and the judge
Donald Trump's legal team is set to use
a previously undisclosed conflict of
Interest as grounds for appealing a
recent verdict that orders the former
president to pay uh Ean Carroll 83.3
million Trump's attorney Alina habba
told the New York Post she was
previously unaware that Manhattan's
federal judge Lewis Kaplan who presided
over the case worked with Robert Kaplan
Carol's attorney at the Paul Weiss
riffkin Wharton and Gerson law firm in
the early 90s habba says neither the
judge nor Robert Kaplan revealed this
professional history it was never
disclosed it's insane and so uous Haba
said uh asserting the
non-disclosed uh counts as an Ethics
violation early in her career Roberto
worked as an associate at the firm
during the same period as judge Kaplan
was a partner until his 1994 appointment
to the federal bench by then President
Bill Clinton 15 facts that people don't
know about uh uh Ean Carroll number one
uh Bergdorf Goodman has no surveillance
video of the alleged Incident That's one
two there are zero witnesses to alleged
sexual attacks three Carol first came
forward conveniently with the
allegations while promoting her book
what do we need men for in 2019 four
Carol was unable to remember when his
alleged attack even occurred she told
her lawyer in 2023 this question the
when the when the date has been
something I've been constantly trying to
pin down it's pretty strange to say that
in 2023 the Donna Blazer dress she
claims to have worn during the alleged
incident was not even available at the
time of her claims
she never came forward with these
allegations over the years despite
constantly being open about sexuality
posting things that they were very
sexual in nature on social media many of
which Trump has
shared seven she said she was never
raped telling the New York Times podcast
the daily every woman gets to choose her
word every woman gets to choose how she
describes it this is my way of saying it
this is my word this is the word is my
fight my word is not the victim word I
have not I have not been raped she
continues have something that has not
been done to me I fought that's the
thing she named her cat vagina wow out
of all the names you can name her cat so
did I her dog or her cat was named
vagina the judge wouldn't allow us to
put it in there out of all the things
it's kind of weird you name your cat
vagina Joe tacopina an attorney for
Trump pointed out in May 2023 that
Carol's entire story has an incredible
similarities to 2012 episode of Law and
Order Special Victims Unit in that
episode titled theater and tricks an
individual talks about a rape fantasy in
bergd Goodman's the same department
store where Carol claims the incident
took place 10 speaking of shows Carol
loved Trump's show The Apprentice I was
a big fan of the show very impressed by
it she said 11 Carol made a joke
associate sex and bergd off Goodman in a
November 1993 edition of Le which was
before the alleged Trump attack took
place 12 Carol is finally backed by
anti-trump Democrat Mega donor Reed
Hoffman who has openly admitted to
visiting convicted sex offender Jeffrey
Epstein's private idland 13 whoops
Democrat Party activist backer as well
you know in state okay we can skip this
11 14 the lawsuit was only able to
proceed after Democrat created the adult
supervisor Act of 2022 and 15 Carol one
said most people think of rape as sexy
she said that to obviously uh Anderson
Cooper but watch this here when Rachel
mattow uh uh asks the question what are
you going to do with the money little
weird here watch this
you've talked about using some of
Trump's money that you're about to get
um to help Shore up women's rights do
you know what that might be what that
might look like yes
Rachel me I had such such great ideas
for all the good I'm going to do with
this money first thing Rachel you and I
are going to go shopping we're going to
get completely new wardrobes new shoes
motorcycle for crawling new fishing rod
for look at all look at thew how
uncomfortable they are it's yours Rachel
penel you fre you want France fishing in
France no fake laugh all right all right
look at that yeah awkward looks like
blinking when when Biden
[Laughter]
talks if if me fishing in France could
do something for women's rights I would
take the hit you know I would obviously
you can pause that's a little weird
right what are your thoughts on well
guess what I I made a statement on this
podcast um two shows ago three shows ago
Pat and I said no one is paying attent
the media has its day with a headline
Trump is not going to pay this he's
never going to pay this this number 83
is not going to change hands here's
what's going to happen there are so many
elements in here and if you look deep
enough you're finding that the rationale
for appeal in this case is legendary the
number of causes legitimate causes for
appeal the excessive of the award the
conflict of interest between the judge a
judge not disclosing oh yeah we were at
the same law firm and actually I had
responsibility kind of Mentor her whoops
sorry I didn't bring that up all of
these are legitimate causes to come
forth under appeal to do one of three
things demute the verdict dismiss the
verdict or actually remand it for
retrial or and to to to basically put
them in a position where they have to
work this again that's the lowest
probability possible but what we're
looking at here is all the appell at
things usually what happens you're going
to go to appeal and this thing's going
to get reduced mightily and there will
be some agreement she doesn't have a
nickel and she's not getting a nickel
and I hope she's got a savings account I
hope Reed Hoffman has giv her more money
because she's got to fund the appeal
process and the appeal process is is
going to be legendary in this case this
is huge the Dems and the Liberals seem
to think that you can try a case in the
media and get a headline out of it and
that's where you finish it no there's a
due process and the appet process and
it's about to get long but the but the
goal great Point Tom the goal of what
all this is with what they're doing in
Georgia with all these cases with it's
freaking headlines and the average
person Tom isn't doing what we're doing
they're not doing what you're doing Tom
where you're up at night doing all this
all this research all they know right
now is he raped her he in a room and he
has to pay $883 million which she's not
going to pay any of it but look listen
to the conflict of interest okay the
judge remember that picture of that
crazy judge that you guys showed he was
a mentor for the attorney the one that
you just saw Carol um uh Roberta Kaplan
which has no relation to the judge in
the 90s he worked with Carol's attorney
but they never disclose it that guy
that's called a conflict of interest it
shouldn't even be able to go this far
that's going to have this whole case uh
thrown out and then you see that video
undisclosed is the issue undisclosed you
have to to short and they like guys
think about it and I I I look this up
too the it's all a ploy it's all
election interference the same lady
that's Prosecuting Trump in uh Fon
County Georgia what's her name Fanny
Willis you know what she's subpoena for
right now investigation corruption so
it's it's it's hilarious how once you
realize their game accuse the enemy of
what you're guilty of yourself that's
all we keep seeing this is all a sham
but going back to is it going to work
Pat is this going to work for the
average voter that's sitting there going
that's not that doesn't see it like how
we see the moment they see him they're
going to go nope rape the girl in a in a
con in in a store in a dressing room and
that's it bro that's what this I think
it's going to work for the people that
are never going to vote for Trump
anyways but for people that are the 12%
of America they're going to be like what
are you doing cuz cuz she the girl Ean
Carol makes the average person who has
common sense and the ability to reason
you know what the average person says
that actually is part of the 12% camp
with the ability to reason those are the
people that run America by the way you
know what they say you think I'm stupid
why why hey Rachel why do you insult me
like this don't patronize me this woman
is full of it Anderson Cooper you think
we're dumb you're just trying to find a
reason to hurt this guy they may even
say I don't even like this candidate
Donald let's just say they say that
right but I don't like what you're doing
to them and that's manipulation y the
12% of America that has the ability to
reason and that's common sense I'm not
talking the ones that are going to vote
Republican no matter what I'm not
talking about the side that's going to
vote Democrat no matter what I'm talking
about the 12% in the middle that's kind
of like saying yeah look man I don't
like what you're doing here I'm not with
it you think we're dumb we're not dumb
you're making me want to vote for him
even more and they're flipping people
the more they do this the more flipping
people to Trump that's what they're
doing yeah the polls show it's not
working
fully agree with what you're saying
things like this make an average person
be like dude I don't like what they're
doing to this guy because I'm putting it
in the same categor as what they did to
Tate what they did to Russell BR what
amber herd tried to do to Johnny Depp
the biggest divide in this country at
this point I have some stats to show you
is no longer between Republicans
Democrats blacks and whites identity
politics it's no longer race religion
it's it's genuinely gender and there's
this patriarchy uh feminism movement
going on right there that is dividing
America if you look at these stats right
here it it's very clear the Stark divide
that's happening right now Democrats
versus Republicans so this is gender by
marital status okay married men almost
60% to 40% Republicans if you're a
married man you're more likely to be
Republic got you okay if you're a
married woman you're also more likely to
be Republican if you're an unmarried man
just a single dude that's me you're more
likely to be Republican and that has
shifted here's the biggest Stark example
if you're an unmarried woman the Chelsea
Handler types
68% likely to be Democrat so this deep
divide that we're talking about right
now and it's sort of like the best image
of it is four women on camera on MSNBC
laughing at Trump being accused of these
crimes we're going to go fishing yeah
it's like as a dude you have to look and
be like yeah even if I'm not the biggest
Trump fan myself you have to look and be
like this is all a sham this is all
how many of these four are
married by the way is Rachel M married I
don't Rachel M is a lesbian okay okay
great married is Ean Caroll married or
is she single no but she's dating her
cat vagina okay those two girls right
there are they married the lawyers I
have no clue they're just getting look
at the ring finger she doesn't have a
ring finger the lady to the left right
so these are these are women these are
part of the these are women who hate men
their whole agenda is to bring down the
patriarchy Rob can you play the clip to
see if the lady on the right is married
just turn off the audio because we don't
want to hear the voice just I want to
hear the hand moving single women see if
there anything with that hand on the
Right Moving no the lawyers locked in I
don't even know if those are okay that
one finger moved but um that you know
when I saw the movie Barbie and I didn't
see it because I like Barbie I wanted to
see from a cultural phenomenon what was
happening right there they
men I'm a big Margo Robbie fan ever
since wolf but they mentioned the word
patriarchy 12 times patriarchy
patriarchy we got to bring down the pat
go back go back go back she left no
pause is that a ring I don't know that's
a booger though that's definitely a SN
but the point is the the starkest divide
that we're seeing in the country right
now is between men and women and they
want to be basically deepen this divide
and Trump is there any more clear
example of the patriarchy than theill
billionaire playboy model dating
president of the United States but it
goes deep to me it's the people like her
like that's the problem it's the Rachel
matal besides her besides the lawyer
besides the mainstream media Rachel
madal along with Joy Reed your favorite
hairstyle having girl it's just the the
amount of like soullessness that they
have that that they could do this and
laugh and berate and hope like cuz I I
just sent um rob a clip of Rachel madow
is one of those people Patrick that just
is completely full of crap full of crap
full of crap and then they flip they
flip everything I I we have to show
right now but I show I I sent him a clip
of her completely lying over and over
and over and then she flips at the end
talking about Trump and stuff it's the
same thing with Joy Reed they're all the
same they're all can we show this m let
play this look how much full of she
is this is her in 2017 the bottom line
of this dossier the bottom line
allegation point of it is that the Trump
campaign didn't just benefit from Russia
interfering in our presidential campaign
the point of this is they colluded they
helped they were in on it this is kind
of a real story the connections between
the Trump servers and the alphab bank
servers were
real they were covert Communications
that someone was trying to hide that the
Trump organization and alphab Bank
appear to have been trying to hide lie
false now we know that the vaccines work
well enough that the virus stops with
every vaccinated person lie hold on lie
a vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus the virus does not infect them the
virus cannot then use that person to go
anywhere El they ID ready cannot use a
vaccinated person as more people watch
they don't want to give Trump air time
and other news organizations have
generally stopped giving an unfiltered
live platform to remarks by former
president trump it is not out of spite
it is not a decision that we relish it
is a decision that we regularly
revisit um and honestly earnestly it is
not an easy decision by the way you can
PA it right there you know you know what
never lies here's what never lies
results don't lie how's MSNBC doing
honestly Tom how is MSNBC doing you can
you can say whatever you want Rachel
there's this thing that they call data
stats numbers does it favor you with
that smug look on your face if it does
you're right it doesn't your numbers
suck it's so bad that to make it nice
didn't she go down Rob to only doing her
show once a week instead of five days a
week is that what happened to her she
went down to doing thought she was about
to yeah I thought they almost got rid of
her I think they only do it once a week
or once a month instead of the regularly
five days and you see but mind you now
MBC MSNBC was in the face of data in the
face of ratings in the face of AD Reven
Vue in the face of when they don't have
an election year or a war you know the
news news organizations financially
suffer if you don't have an election a
war or massive massive presidential
controversy so they were looking for
money and they're looking in the couch
cushions to see if there's a couple
coins in there and they revamped the
contracts of many of the talent and
supposedly in response to the revamp
mattow says well you know if you're not
going to do this and I'm not going to do
that and she ended up on a reduced
schedule but it just just I I this is to
Pat's point this is in response to data
and it's not a growing thriving you know
financially you know rocket ship they're
responding to real data and real dollars
that they don't have but but it just
bothers me as a human being you know you
know she can't be stupid bro that you
are lying to us you are giving us
misinformation people you're making
people hate each other and you're the
problem when when when Trump said that
like Jim MAA and CNN the enemy of the
people you're lying to the people to
make us hate each other and it's not
working it ain't working I just don't
like it you're not going to like it
that's that's a that's the job of what
they got they're going to keep doing it
but your Rachel matter will switch to
weekly show under new MSNBC contract in
why is it a new contract the old one
wasn't profitable yeah that's the listen
here's the the best part about
capitalism man capitalism is the best it
doesn't lie you know yesterday Chris and
I were talking Cuomo and he said
something uh uh about politicians and I
shared a tweet I said you tweet this I'm
going to share it right now he said
politicians are the only people we pay
to do nothing politicians are the only
people we pay to do nothing you know
what happens in capitalism if you pay
people that do nothing guess what
happens you know not only you go out of
business you get fired okay you get
fired the market exposes you you're done
period there is no ifs and buts about it
right you're done capitalism is exposed
in Rachel mat the system she trashes
that she's not the biggest fan of okay
is getting her to get her show to go
weekly and by the way it's not like
she's old how old is Rachel mat she
looks she looks very good would say I'm
not I'm not even hating on her I think
she looks very young and good at 50
years old you going to weekly you know
what that means what basketball player
retires young the ones that are no
longer good and nobody wants to sign a
contract to them okay what person on TV
stops doing shows and goes to weekly
those who are no no longer bringing
money to the company no one as big of a
names she's been the face of MSNBC for
how many years guess what you're moving
on to being yeah so anyways let's move
on to the next story she's getting a
little too many minutes here we got to
go to next story okay next story here uh
I'll go
to uh uh uh the paycheck situation here
workers are paying to get their
paychecks early it's payday lending on
steroids one expert said as and it again
buy now pay later then it's this one
here millions of American workers are
using earn wage access it's called Ewa
programs allowing them to access a
portion of their pay before pay they
often for a fee these programs have
gained popularity due to their benefits
including quick access to funds for
emergencies according to the latest data
from Doos insights in the employee
sponsor Market alone $9.5 billion in
wages was accessed early during the
2020s tripled from 3.2 billion in 2018
the number of transactions was increased
threefold over that period to 55.8
million transactions from 18.6 million
people that means about you know some a
third of those it's just the same people
coming back to it while some see these
programs as helpful experts warn that
overuse and high fees which me translate
into interest rate uh of up to 400
400% pbd a joke wow 400% can lead to
financial harm the industry rapid growth
has raised concerns about it becoming
akin to Payday lending on steroids dude
this is something that I feel very
strongly about I did a video across the
street you know there's a place called
Amscot yep I walked in there because
I've been talking I've been shouting
from the rooftops for years about this
business model you know I'm always
saying FTM follow the money this
business model I don't even know how
it's legal okay this business model is
predatory and it is lethal for the
consumer I talk about something called
the Seas of debt everything starts with
a C whether it's credit cards whether
it's cars whether it's colleges whether
it's Consumer loans whether it's cribs
AKA mortgages nothing is as bad as cash
advances AKA payday loans the whole
premise of debt you know they say
there's good debt there's bad debt well
I say debt inherently is bad you're
losing the interest rate game how much
are you paying for your money
400% credit cards are not allowed to
charge sorry it's a myth credit cards
are not allowed to charge more than what
25% how do these guys get away with
charging two three
4% on your money if you want to invest
your money in the stock market yeah do
you know what a good rate of return is
if you're S&P did 10% this year this
past year did 25% so this is the calcul
this year so let's just say you got 300,
$100 borrowed 14-day terms okay
$33 is the finance charges annual
percentage comes down to $2 187% that's
how it's done so but to a person they're
like dude I'll pay the 33 bucks but to
this business they're like dude you know
what kind of return we're making no one
in wall Street's making a kind of return
ring Tom your thoughts on this well the
the increase of this I I first of all if
you haven't seen that video from Adam
you should go watch it it's it's a
brilliant breakdown and the other part
of this the headline by way it's the
CNBC finally puts the truth in the
headline it's payday lending on steroids
it is that's terrible what it's saying
is that Americans are facing cash flow
pinches the main street is the the
market was up and there was a big year
for the S&P last year Market's all-time
high but main stream is in trouble the
amount of debt they have is in trouble
and now we're seeing data showing that
this is showing a cash flow problem they
need the $300 before they get their
paycheck when next week not next year
they're trying to get the paycheck next
week and they got a cash flow problem
Main Street is pinched and in deep
trouble and these are predatory CU they
make it seem so easy so convenient
they're selling ease convenient and
speed and access we're on every corner
every corner in what neighborhood it is
it's absolutely predatory and it shows
that there's a a group of Americans on
on Main Street that are pinched yeah and
here's the biggest problem well we all
heard the stats that two-thirds of
Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck it's almost like drugs once you
you get started on this thing it's over
and you're just working at your job it's
not like you're making more money you're
hooked you're going to come back next
paycheck and you're going to come back
next paycheck and you say things like
well it's only 30 bucks cuz you made the
next paycheck smaller exactly it's only
30 bucks it's only 50 bucks and they got
you bro you're in their spiderweb you're
ain't getting out it's very very scary
and predatory yeah there's no question
about it I mean this is this is when you
got to sit there and kind of weigh in
your habits and what you're doing that's
helping you and hurting you and some of
these habits that people get hooked on
is destroying people's lives by the way
the only reason somebody has to do that
is because they put themselves in a
financial situation in a bind that's
causing them to make desperate decisions
and these companies are simply sitting
there saying don't come to us go to
somebody else it's like casinos what is
the best commercial that one Harris
Casino ran you know if you have a
gambling problem and you come to Harris
Casino and you're having a hard time
call this 1800 number we don't want you
to lose are your money on
Harris problem want you to yeah okay and
cuz you understand like how that kind of
works and then you call them so look I
think I have a gambling problem what
should I do well how much money you got
left in your credit card $1,200 how much
you own debt
$50,000 look have you thought about
putting that 1,200 on 23 it's Michael
Jordan's number if you win we can pay
that off with one time why don't you go
back again it has to be your choice why
don't you go back and put it on 23 m and
if you win for a small 5% fee we'll take
it from you but at the same time we'll
celebrate you'll be able to pay off your
Deb what do you think about that we'll
put you on the
billboard by the way we'll give you a
free hotel room in Vegas we'll play for
your state come on in have a great time
youd appreciate this just really fast
this when I was going crazy and drinking
it I was in LA at Commerce Casino I'm
playing poker okay and I look on the
wall and I see the 1800 gambling problem
and in front of the table I go I'm in a
hand and I go can I just really fast I
call the number on speaker everybody's
like shocked the Dealer's mad and they
go you know what's your problem I go
listen I got pocket Jacks I think this
guy might have Kings and there's a pause
and lady goes what the hell is your
problem I go okay you don't you don't
play poker and I hung up on her that
number that number they're actually
hilarious that is hilarious okay let's
go to the next story uh next story Let's
uh um I go to the Super Bowl one at the
end I like that story but we'll go to
that at the end okay
so which one should we do let's go to
Trump team reached out to RFK early on
about serving asvp wouldn't write it off
this is a New York Post story now again
some people say this is true some people
say it's not true but let's read this
individuals within Trump's Circle made
initial uh inquiries to RFK about the
possibility of him serving at Trump's
running mate in 2024 pres presidential
campaign with expressions of Interest
coming right out of the box when Kennedy
announced his candidacy in April 2023
one Insider remarked uh anything's
possible I wouldn't write It Off by any
means although Kennedy an independent
candidate has consistently rejected the
idea donors have supported both Trump
and Kennedy acknowledged that the
concept of drafting Kennedy as a running
mate remains a topic of discussion
within Trump circles despite potential
ideolog ideological differen of Steve
banon a former White House strategist
for Trump has endorsed the idea
suggesting that a trump Kennedy ticket
could lead to a massive
Landslide very very interesting same
time a day later senior Trump campaign
adviser rules out RFK joining as a VP so
top eight comes out a day later saying
there's no way this is
possible uh uh senior uh Trump adviser
Chris lasva refuted that the campaign
has never has had ever reached out to
Kennedy and closed the door on doing so
in the future to bvp this is 100% fake
news no one from the Trump campaign ever
reached out approach RFK uh or or ever
will one of the most liberal and radical
environmentalists in the country for all
the fake news update your stories
lasciva said wow on X earlier that day
the post reported that individuals close
to Trump had reached out to Kennedy who
is now running as an independent
candidate for president and by the way
RFK comes out hinting that he may run as
a Libertarian Adam thoughts on the story
this is 100% not real this is 100% fake
and I don't use word 100% lightly uh
he's nowhere on the top candidates list
you know I'm all about Vegas talking
about when you're going and doing your
vetting betting in Vegas look at the
Vegas odds you want to pull them up Rob
here's who the leading candidate is for
vvp two of them are female so Alise
stonic she's the one that became famous
uh for basically the Harvard lashing out
against the Harvard presidents exactly
Harvard mitm amazing and then my girl
Christy know who I think and then our
guy Vic that's a top three you got
sleepy Ben Carson out there you got Tim
Scott that I don't think is going to be
the guy got you got Sarah hucke
beautiful person you got Carrie Lake
tutor Nixon not a name uh and then
Tucker and then if you scroll down look
at these odds by the
way can you scroll down even more Rob
that's it you're going to have to keep
scrolling and scrolling and scrolling to
see Robert NF Kennedy's name it's like
8,000 zoom in a little bit Yeah Marco
Rubio on that
list where's Pence up a little hey Doug
there's Doug go up a bit a little B
let's oh keep going up because there's
more names keep going up keep going up
that's that's what you got to do no no
okay yeah so car
Tucker just wait till you see where RFK
I can't accept gifts Pence Candice Owens
Rubio Ivanka Glen youngan Mar Taylor
green with so the point is Mike Pence
has a better chance of 84,000 okay
gotcha that's a crazy bat Kanye West has
a better chance exactly Kanye West has a
better chance meaning Chris Christie
yeah just Christie whose whole campaign
wasum this guy has a better chance
in RFK so I get that it's fod and I
great that it's have a conversation and
thank you for these news outlets that
basically allowed us to have this
conversation FTM y'all follow the money
there's no chance RFK thanks Tom there's
no chance that RFK is GNA be the VP
selection go for it I I thought you were
rapping I'm sorry about no Tom do your
thing bro so individuals anyway you can
find me on I'm on man he's on man
everybody Tom's Canadian well yo Mike
just messaged me that's a great bet for
RFK a $100 bet Mike pays back what
$84,000 for your $100 bet and that might
be a bet you we have to make so we here
at hara's casino yeah exactly you can be
and V some so what I love about this
story right there Adam let's dissect
this do it who said it the post reported
MH this is where ladies and
gentlemen this is
where reputable Publications or partly
reputable Publications literally just
make up stories individuals close to
Trump this whole story is written
paragraphs
around individuals close to
Trump this the people are saying
reportedly reached out allegedly there's
nobody there individuals close to trump
it could have been the Bellman that he
was walking by and at that moment he was
close to Trump yeah come on this is this
is an example the fake news happens when
they make stuff up Publications just
make it up and that's what they hang it
on that simple statement is what keeps
them legally out of court well it was
individuals close to Trump and we don't
reveal our sources yeah whistleblowers
or we what would that being being said
looking at the odds at least stonic this
is you remember we had that whole
conversation it's a congress person in
New York but it's former blah blah blah
blah blah she's the only person from New
York on this list remember that
conversation we had and Lee zeldon is
nowhere on that list correct so but
that's the part you know the one thing
that I called you on remember what I
called you on what I told you I said the
the the job of a great tight Camp a
great tight camp is it's very hard this
is why you don't let everybody in you
don't let everybody in there's people
that think they're in but only the in
people know who's in and who's not in
okay and the way you test some people to
think if they're in or not is leak a
little bit to them and see if it stays
or not gotcha and you don't leak them a
level one tier one type of insight
information you leak them tier four and
then if they leak a tier four 100%
they're going to leak a tier one but
then once you have identified who a tier
one is the tier one one people's job is
one thing you know what they do for a
living confuse everybody that's your job
the job of a tier one advisor is to
confuse anybody that's not a tier one
your job is to do that 247 in the most
smoothest possible way and the tier one
people who are on the inside are doing a
really good job confusing the out
of America CU yeah cuz nobody knows
that's exactly the job of a tier one
advisor brilliant that's exactly what a
tier one adviser does a lot of them
think they're tier one they could be
tier two tier three you still trust a
tier two yeah not like a tier one you
still trust a tier three but not like a
tier one you still trust a tier four but
not like a tier one everybody is like
yeah I'm his boy you know Trump and I do
this and yeah look at this he texted me
look at this we call this great you're
part of a tier four tier five but a tier
one is not going around showing text
messages to Trump Tier one doesn't do
that quiet tier one doesn't go brag
about how close they are to somebody
it's just here's who we are advisor
advisor and you know know exactly what
I'm talking about there's a very big
difference between tier one and
everybody by the way Tom just told me
what you guys were talking about so he's
a tier four for sure he made the
announcement to for
sure but for $100 Tom will tell you
what's going on
on that's a whole different story help
me beat Adam I'll tell you
anything them for the secret imagine
that would be the funniest thing 999 the
next toan situation here so three US
troops killed by Iranian back drone
strike in Jordan Biden vows
alation and Bon vows retaliation three
American Service members killed and more
than two dozen others wounded in drone
attack in Jordan with Iranian back
militias believed to be responsible
President Joe Biden vow retaliation
saying have no doubt we will hold all
these all those responsible to count out
of time in a manner are choosing the
attack marked are choosing okay the
attack marked the first time American
troops had been directly targeted since
the start of Israel Hamas war in October
while the US supported Israel against
Hamas it attempted to prevent the
conflict from spreading further to the
Middle East Iranian back militias have
carried out numerous attacks in the
region in recent months targeting US
troops in Iraq and Syria as well as
American ships and Commercial vessels in
the Red Sea and Gulf of Aiden so and
then by the way he gives his whole
speech Biden gives chilling nuclear
warning over attacking Iran after
kamakazi
drone Rob if you can pull up that clip
where Joy Reed accidentally says what
she says at the end it's a hot mic I
I'll read this and then you prepare the
video EX un weapons inspector David
Albright warns against launching uh
direct strikes on Iran emphasizing the
risk could lead Iran to believe building
nuclear warheads is the best option you
certainly don't want to attack Iran Now
by any means but you do need to
retaliate certainly any retaliation
should be directed to the group with a
message to Iran control your proxies one
of the reasons to do that is you don't
want Iran to feel it's being backed into
a corner whale where it feels that that
building nuclear weapon is its best way
out Iran has quite a nuclear weapons
capability that they've put together
over the last 20-some years albite uh
Albright sheds light on the capabilities
of kamakazi drones used in the attack
stating they carry quite a bit of high
explosive and they're pre-programmed to
it stationary targets they can hit
pretty precisely a military base and
highlighted that Iran could produce
enough weapons grade uranium for nuclear
weapon within a week but watch this here
here's Jo J weed fantastic here if he
can play this clip please go for it over
the weekend President Biden said he's
ready to take action if Congress is
serious about solving the Border
issue if that bill were the law today
I'd shut down the border right now and
fix it quickly and Congress needs to get
it done starting another
War go back go back 10 seconds and
played from like 9
seconds Donald watch this
no no she just flat out is against
what's going on i' shut down the border
right now and fix it quickly and
Congress needs to get it done starting
another War Joey watch your
language Jo Jo it's almost as if the
Trump hair has made her into an anti-war
trump-like figure and it's weird how
think about this remember I told you
about soulless people like Rachel madal
dude that's not how they think yeah Adam
it's it is to me because she's out here
what you're saying is like what she says
and how she lives are two different
things is that what that's what you
believe I believe you're not 100% you
believe that I I believe that she can go
on there race baiting country's racist
Trump is evil this but then guess what
behind closed doors you know what she's
saying these effers want to start a war
I'm anti this so she's not the she's not
really who you see when she's in front
of the camera do you think Tom I Not
Cool by the way you think that's the
same AI organization targeting uh Taylor
Swift That's targeting saying those
words or was it really her saying it
look I got nothing to say about watch
her come out and say the following
imagine she comes out tomorrow and says
that's not me it's it's Ai and that's
going to be the problem with it too
right and you know um I look at Joy Reed
and I I don't care what she looks like I
just listen to what she says I listen to
her opinions I see a person who's being
completely manipulate manipulated by the
media to present things on the mic and
then you're seeing the real person come
out on the hot mic so I think it shows
that there's probably a lot of reporters
out there cashing a paycheck living in
conflict in their heart and their mind
because they're paid Talking Heads and
they feel things underneath I think
there's a second thing H there's a
bigger story if you you listen into that
our president just blamed Congress for
his inability to close the border if the
law was there I would close the border
right now he has had the worst week
Biden has had on Border issues he's got
26 now States saying you don't care care
about the good of Americans that live in
these states we're going to support
Texas and New Mexico and Arizona by the
way they're in there too for what's
going on at the border you went to your
freaking Supreme Court to get the
Supreme Court to say the border the
little line of the border now that's a
jurisdiction to the federal people only
they can put up walls and therefore if
that's your barbwire that's not federal
barbwire they can cut it that's all the
Supreme Court said and so Biden is
putting the putting Politics on
immigration way above the needs and the
the genuine situations that are
happening to citizens of Arizona
California New Mexico and Texas that are
on the Mexican border and then he has
the gall he well excuse me his speech
writers and his policy makers have the
gall to prop him up this week and say if
there is a law right there I would shut
down the border right now and I want
Congress to work on it he's blaming
Congress you see what he's doing that's
a bigger story that's in the middle of
this look at it it's ridiculous you have
the states having to Marshall resources
because it's not just the political
statement those are refugees and and
migrants and illegal aliens coming
across that that are sick that need
services that have nowhere to live that
are living in the street that are human
Wast is in the street Have encampments
and Have crime There's real things
happening here and all he's and all
they're thinking about from Washington
hey here come the voters here come the
voters yeah and so I think that's the
bigger thing is he just blamed Congress
for the order problem yeah by the way
and I sent I sent rob a video of this
new Caravan of 8,000 people coming here
but what people don't realize is a
number one the president of United
States didn't address the country about
this people our soldiers dying let's
stay on
IR am right now hold on blink said this
is what people aren't realizing blink
speaking not Trump I mean not Biden and
he said we have not seen a situation as
dangerous as the one that we are facing
now across the region since 1973 this is
getting us ready for another bigger
conflict with Iran and they're trying to
be like oh no dud we're losing soldiers
we're at War thank you Vinnie for
bringing it back to Joy Reed is just a
distraction we know what's going on at
the border right now but let's stay
focused on what is actually happening in
the Middle East that could potentially
turn into a war there's a difference
between a proxy war there's a difference
between a regional conflict and there's
God forbid the difference between a
World War III and I don't like using
those terms ever but Iran that's the
problem is is is is arguably the biggest
problem in the world right now China
economically is a major problem and
China who's is basically funding Iran we
all know what's going on in Russia and
Ukraine that is regional at this point
but the spill there's nothing spilling
over because due to Nato nothing
spilling over between Russia and Ukraine
into the rest of the world uh Iran
everything that's going on with what I
call the Triple H crew Hamas the houthis
and Hezbollah they're all funded by Iran
you know you you've called 2024 what uh
chaos the year of chaos there's nobody
sewing more chaos in the world than Iran
okay the difference between chaos is
order and what the order is trying to do
the United States the EU whether it's
Israel whether it's any Western or
democracy of the world is basically
trying to have order and stability in
the world and you have people like the
houthi rebels in the Red Sea attacking
basically messing with people's money
cargo everything that's going on with
that now Iran let's not forget here
three US soldiers were killed yep okay
servicemen were killed by an Iranian
proxy now Iran has said you know you
know it wasn't us every single of these
issues whether it's the houthi rebels in
the Red Sea whether it's Hezbollah North
of Israel whether it's Hamas they all
get their money from Iran every single
one of them
okay and Iran needs to be dealt with one
way or another so the administration
come out and said basically there's
three ways to deal with Iran number one
there's a direct strike on Iran I think
everybody's looking to avoid that
they're striking their proxies one of
the Triple H crew or there's economic
sanctions we've seen what's happening to
economic sanctions there's ways to avoid
them by the way $6 billion they gave to
Iran for hostages come on have we not
realized you can't keep funding
terrorist regimes and there's no way of
getting their their mindset out of this
why because in America we have something
called separation of church and state
whether whatever your beliefs are
whatever your belief in God is all good
you're not letting that Infuse into all
your politics I get it some people like
our current Speaker of the House infuses
it and people say I don't know it's a
little separation there is zero
separation between MOS and state in Iran
it's a theocracy run by a mafia likee
regime
and it's very scary and we don't know
what to deal with it and slowly but
surely they're continuing to build up
their nuclear arsenal we don't know
what's going on there we all remember
what Obama did and funding that and the
hundred million then Trump came out and
pulled out of that let's not
forget before October
7th Saudi Arabia and Israel were how
close to having a peace treaty very
close very close Iran looked at that and
said Iran and Saudi Arabia this is the
whole Sunni Shia everything that's going
on on there they looked at that and they
said holy Israel has already made
peace with Egypt with Jordan with the
UAE with Bahrain with whatever countries
that are the now they're going for the
big dog Saudi Arabia our mortal enemy
across the Red Sea and if we allow this
to happen we're screwed basically
because they profit off of chaos and if
you're putting together peace treaties
and Order and
alliances Iran basically will be
subjugated to watch this though this is
what's interesting this is story that
just came out rob you put this on the
addendum right can you pull up the story
real quick so Russia and China matter of
fact I think this came out today this
morning if I'm not mistaken today's the
30th yeah Russia and China rush to
defend Ally Iran as us prepares response
okay here we go if those two get
involved there's there's uh it's it's a
war amongst the world which there's a
name for it right when the there's war
amongst different countries in the world
weird so Russia and China have urged the
US to exercise restraint can you imagine
Russia and China telling us to pump your
brakes restraint in its response to
killing of three American soldiers in a
drone attack on a Bas in Jordan Kremlin
spokesperson Demetri pesov stated now is
the time for steps to deescalate
tensions wow China's foreign minister
spokesman Wang when be said we hope that
all relevant parties will remain calm
and restrained to avoid falling into a
vicious cycle of retaliation and prevent
further escalation the United States
including President Joe Biden and
defense secretary Lloyd Austin has vowed
to respond to the attack Biden
spokesperson mentioned a very
consequential response even though the
administration stress it does not seek
war with Iran overd distract potential
options include attacking Iranian
Personnel in Syria or Iraq as well as
Iranian Naval assets in Persian Gulf do
you know who did this let me tell you
who did this do you remember when uh uh
when um uh Trump uh they killed gam
solman yeah you remember how Iran
responded they they shot like an un
exactly they shot down an empty base and
bragged about it nobody was in that
building when they shot it down do you
know what it sounds like right now it's
flipped us is going to attack an empty
place and not have anything be done so
us officially is acting like Iran when
they were trying to show strength by by
attacking somewhere that they knew no
military personnel from us was there why
because they did not want Trump to do
anything can you imagine that Russia and
China are telling you to pump your
brakes Even though three of your people
were killed and dozens were heard hey us
let us lecture you we are Russia in
China we'd like to lecture you and talk
to you like an older brother Hey Joe
Biden and us I don't think this is a
good time to retaliate yeah I think this
is a good time to kind of sit around and
not do anything about it it just doesn't
behoove you to do that I'm sorry China
and Russia who are you according to
America well wait a minute where were
you China when this guy named Richard
broke a deal and change your economy
while your people were poor an American
president changed your life China hey
Russia just so we get it straight here
an American
president asked your leader who
eventually had conscience that was
hurting him saying hey Mr gorbachov tear
down this wall and gorbachov because he
could reason and he loved his people
saying what the hell are we doing to our
people he actually listen us has led you
China us has led you Russia who are you
to tell us what we ought to do I'm sorry
you're not our advisers you you are not
our advis
this is the part where for me I have a
challenge that we are at a point right
now where they're lecturing us who are
you to lecture us bro doesn't sit very
well with me at all this is probably the
most annoying part of the story we read
so far because when when you're when
you're a country that changed so many
other countries lives and the people in
those countries have a better life
because of you and you want to tell us
what to do after three of our people got
killed life doesn't work that way you
cross the line when you do something to
our servicemen who put their lives on
the line whose wives and kids are behind
they're never going to see their husband
again they're never going to see their
father again they're never going to see
their son their brother again you want
to tell us to not do anything about it
okay bro we don't share the same values
by the way I'm I have a very different
position here there's a camp that's
saying we shouldn't attack okay and some
of those guys are you know uh uh
conservatives who are magga Community
saying we shouldn't attack we shouldn't
start another War we rean the Rhino
people you know the the some of the
neocons are saying what go for it go for
it this this you know what I like here's
what I prefer I don't even want you to
think about doing that because we put
the fear in you pre so in your mind you
know what you say if I do something I
know what they're going to do so guess
what the best offense sometimes is you
know you the best defense is offense but
to me it's actually the best defense is
when you put the fear of death mhm I
dare you to do something do something
see what happens but if you don't I
promise you we will not have any
problems it's a very simple negotiation
look man let me tell you why I'm here
I'm going to be the president next four
years I may get reelected for another
four years okay I want to have a very
simple conversation with you I'd like us
to be able to do business together I
know your number one priority is your
country it ought to be it should be
China first and Putin I know you're
number one by the way I would have a
meeting with the top three people Putin
and G we would have an location that we
would all be comfortable talking to we
would break Brett and I would say look
guys let me just kind of straight up
tell you guys where you're at you've
been around the block for a lot longer
than I have I'm a rookie president I
just got in but I love America and
you've been around the block a lot
longer than I have because you're China
I'm us right your number one priority is
China it should be and I respect it I
fully understand it your number one
priority is Russia I fully accept it
that's a number one number one priority
my number one priority is America we
will continue to lead I would like to
have a good relationship sh with you
guys but let me make something very
straight the more you do proxy and you
make our life a living hell and you make
things challenging here with us I'm
going to do 10 times that to you but
guess what if you don't do any of it and
you have any issues you call me directly
I'm going to talk to you anytime you can
call me I will pick up to talk to you we
will have a good relationship together I
would like to see us the next eight
years we all Prosper you do your thing
with your family we do our thing we try
to lower temperature worldwide I'm a
very easygoing guy we shouldn't have any
issues but if you touch anybody in
America it'll be the worst day of your
life if you do that is that clear can we
have some nice tea and caviar here let's
enjoy some sushi let's see let's talk
tell me about your family tell me about
your kids I guarantee you that's not the
approach our president's taken and they
sit there thinking this is a joke on
what's going on in America doesn't sit
well with me when you choose to increase
the temperature to us the greatest
country in the world I I don't I don't
file for this kind of conversation on
you you sitting here lecturing us on
what we ought to do you don't get to
tell America what to do America changed
your life not the other way around think
can we go to the next story you look
like you want to say I was just going to
say everything you're talking about was
what Ronald Reagan coined peace through
strength like don't with me unless
you want you know around and find
out uh we're we're very we're we're
we're we're we're we've proven the
system of capitalism works and we've
created jobs worldwide we have we have
saved so many different people's lives
indirectly now everyone's always going
to go to what America's done bad to but
trust me capitalism's changed a lot of
people's lives in countries it never had
anything to do with jobs created
worldwide it ain't the philosophies that
America created that's hurting other
Natures it's dumb people that come in
that one war that can't defend the
greatest country in the world that
allows somebody to think you can come
run and push America run you can't do
that to America that doesn't sit well
with me I'm just a regular guy talking
here right now I don't run office or
anything going to be a continual story
though unfortunately well listen we have
to show strength yes but uh
unfortunately we've been so weak the
last three years that nobody fears
America nobody fears America that
doesn't sit well and I think Democrats
have to reckon with that as well is I
they are I think like I had dinner with
a bunch of friends last week um
Republican Democrats and some were super
super left guys and I said what are you
what where you at right now I said would
you consider voting for Trump
100% And I go dude you are as anti-trump
as it gets 2016 2020 things are changing
especially amongst men men are
recognizing yeah bro this soft you know
soft On the Border soft on crime soft on
war exactly men are recognizing despite
whatever you think about Trump you need
a strong leader in there women are going
to look at it totally differently so you
have to you have to give people Grace to
say listen I understood you looked it in
2016 I understand 2020 but times are
different you look under bid right now
Wars around the corner let's go to this
next story and by the way this kind of
goes with the whole story we're talking
we got 27 more minutes we may go a few
more minutes on that CU we got a lot of
stories we're going we're making uh a a
ground today with covering a lot of
stories let me remind you folks quick
reminder again uh between us starting
the podcast and now Thomas caught up a
little bit what I'm just telling you
guys Tom is now officially at
9:47 at the beginning I think he was at
935 he's at 947 and and Adam's at
967 and Vinnie's at 737 737 come on Adam
is 33 away from being the first to First
2000 Thomas 53 away guys it's my
birthday this
weekend can we way needs new shoes
America Vinnie needs new shoes charity
case can I tell you can I tell you guys
how to effectively use this app I've had
hundreds of conversations with people
life-changing type of convers ations
business life finances uh uh so many
people that talk to Tom once they come
back three four five six times so many
people that man with Vinnie they come
back three four five six times a guy on
Sunday and I we maned six times in
Sunday in Sunday was like boom boom boom
boom boom boom full-blown he left a
review saying I cannot believe that I'm
having a conversation with Pat on a
Sunday and he's getting back to me he
did six minutes back to back to back to
back he has something he's dealing with
that's a big policy issue that is trying
to work with politically New Zealand us
but we had back to back to back to back
to back it's a full-on conversation and
allows me to get back to you on my terms
because I'm living a life as well so I'm
like okay here I'm walking to the
bathroom let me respond back to this guy
here I'm getting the call let me respond
back to this guy full-blown conversation
this app the more you use it you will
realize how lifechanging it is and how
the expert giving feedback it's making
you the expert the influencer better
person and it's giving you Direction and
certain answers that people need at
whatever phase they're but having said
that Adam still got a 20-point lead on
Tom let's see who's going to get to all
right let's get to the next story here
man pretending actually I'm going to go
to the next story on Ukraine so Ukraine
five Ukrainian officials arrested over
theft of $40 million you don't say no in
war funds as Ukraine corruption persist
so what do you mean five Ukrainian
officials got $40
million okay so five Ukrainian officials
have been arrested for alleged
embezzling nearly $40 million in funds
designated for the purchase of military
equipment for the war against Russia the
individuals are accused of conspiring
with a Ukrainian armed firm to
misappropriate the funds intended to for
requiring 10,000 100,000 mortar shells
Ukraine's ongoing struggle with
corruption has raised concerns
particularly regarding International Aid
some critics in the US have questioned
whether to provide more Aid to Ukraine
in light of these issues zalinski the
greatest campaigner beggar of all time
that's not the story that's me putting
it in there who campaigned on an
anti-graft platform has faced challenges
in addressing corruption despite this
Ukraine's officials efforts to push back
uh Russia's Invasion have faced
difficulties with limited successes in
the counter offens of primary andrain
exports and actions against Russia's
Black Sea Fleet this is when people
realize when you send money I had a guy
calls me says Pat this was very early on
when we started giving money to Ukraine
says Pat they're making a lot of money
on the inside a lot of military leaders
I'm like dude I'm not buying he said I'm
telling you this guy was
in over there okay sitting down with
some of the top military leaders working
with uh what do you call it zalinski he
says you have no idea how much money is
being made right now okay you have no
idea how much money is being made right
now you know you get some of these
stories that's sent to you through
signal through WhatsApp and all this
stuff yeah you take it for Grant like
don't but that was month one month two
month three okay now this comes out five
of these guys are are getting arrested
for using $40 million of funds that was
used to buy military weapons to when you
read a story like this how do you
process this well first of all Nikki
Haley's probably upset because damn it
that money belonged to Boeing y um wow
what a what a point there that's exactly
right that money should have come back
to Boeing um well first of all I I
always look for false flags and maybe
maybe I'm thinking too much about this
is is this really people trying to reach
in and trying to find what's going on or
is this taking remember how many
billions have been sent over there with
a big b billions double digit billions
have been sent over there and so we got
five guys with 40 million that's like
saying I won the war on drug because I
caught snoop's cousin with 5 PBS of
marijuana come on I I look at this and I
think it's a drop of the bucket compared
to the true corruption that's going on
over there P this is a drop in the
bucket and I wonder if it's just like a
little planted Story five guys getting
arrested to take care by who though by
who who who arrested
him no no meaning who uh planted the
story I look who would do it whose
motive would it be to plant the story I
think it be zelinsky's motive zalinsky
wants to call off the dogs because
you've got half the Republican party has
woken up to the fact and think this guy
is a beggar just taking the billions
home and it's an incredibly corrupt
country and there is CIA reports that
said it was an incredibly corrupt
country decades before the Russian
invasion and so what would be convenient
for zinsky you know what we got to bust
some guys and we got to make this thing
look good Rob can you look up who these
Five Guys Are by the way yeah but see
how high ranking these military guys are
go ahead and Tom this is but by the way
guys This is 40 million uh Kelly made
this point yesterday that we know this
is what they reported can you imagine
how much money has gone and God knows
what they're doing and by the way just a
little fun fact do you know who's going
to be building Ukraine yeah Black Rock
black rock Larry fank with zinsky that's
the whole goal that's the whole keep
sending money and let's keep supporting
these people and keep wearing your flag
on your shirt that's what you're paying
your money tool that's why they call it
the military industrial comp there's a
lot of money in war complex and then
there's the industrial part right yeah
exactly there's that look there if
there's anybody that's upset about the
what's going on in the Middle East with
Iran and the the houthis and the Hamas
and everything like that it's vem
now Ukraine Secret Service so we're
going to assume zalinski knows about
those guys yeah um Security Service you
you Security Service Security Service
the Ukrainian arms firm employees of a
Ukrainian arms firm because probably the
Ukrainian defense Ministry officials it
doesn't say who it is to embezzle the
funds okay so guess what that's an awful
lot of corruption you got the employees
were corrupt the defense Ministry guys
were corrupt and the Ukraine's s spu
Security Service the contract was for
shells with was clinched with leave live
Arsenal in August by the way you know
what's going to happen he'll come right
back to Congress they'll give him the
red carpet he'll be like you have to
give me money and they'll give him trust
me he he'll just I don't think so I
don't think so I if he I if he came
right now this week they'd roll out the
red carpet and they'd give him whatever
he wants it's never going to stop what
I'm saying to you is I think they will
but I think what is starting to happen
is you know it used to be everybody wore
the Ukraine uh uh what do you call it by
the way did you see Jamie Diamond say
I'm not woke at all I'm not this I'm not
May we'll go back to that Rob if you can
prepare that clip we'll go that to that
in a minute how many people were you
seeing Ukraine Flags everybody how many
Ukraine Instagram posts did you see how
many Ukraine I stand with Ukraine the
flags everywhere what happened to all
those flags they're gone just like the
BLM and all that stuff yeah it dies out
but the point is like people are sitting
there saying look man maybe I supported
something that these guys were a money
job and let's stop talking about it so
then the politicians I see you then the
politicians will take it and they'll
redirect with the story and say okay
guys we got to distract Americans
because we cannot talk about Ukraine
anymore throw whole new different story
so America can get over Ukraine and all
the money we spend trust me Americans
have a short-term memory they're like
Finding Nemo they'll forget about it and
move on to the next thing and that's
what they're going through they don't
want another zilinski at the house they
if the left is smart they won't have
another zilinski at the house cuz
they're making themselves look like
idiots strategically it's the dumbest
move if they allow zilinsky to come and
raise money again it's the same thing
like Rachel mat and Ean Carol thinking
it's working it's not so I'm hoping they
do it again yeah I want them to do it go
ahead and do it again I dare you do it
again but if they're smart and strategic
and not dumb and oblivious they won't do
it again I want I want I'm with you I
want pictures this election year bring
him over to dinner have a state dinner
do it again give me a timestamp of March
2024 yeah let me use that I mean to put
it in sort of a weird uh metaphor he's
the ex-girlfriend that that we forgot
about everyone's focused on Gaza and
Israel these days God forbid there
something happens with China and Taiwan
Ukraine and Russia is the last on the
list in 2021 when does everything kind
of get it started
2022 it was all the top of Mind
everyone's wearing the pen we saw Bill
Clinton was wearing a pen I think
recently we saw him Jamie Diamond was
wearing J so it's just not top of Mind
Anyway by the way I I'd like to get uh
the eu's response on this because it
didn't basically say whose money they
stole us has given money the EU given
money I whoever it is money but what
they should have done you remember when
Biden hired what 20,000 IRS agents when
he came into into office go send some of
those agents with Guns by the way they
they were allowed to have guns go send
them over to Ukraine so uh it just goes
to show that we have no clue what's
going on there didn't what was the story
a few months ago when they put an extra
zero on a check it was like $6 billion
that went ay yep uh well that's our
money that's our money question for you
are you partying what are you doing
tonight what plans you got tonight he's
asking zsky in town what are you doing
tonight what are you doing tonight what
you got what you got Joe Biden's in town
Joe's going to be in Miami what he's
going to Miami he probably doesn't even
know where he is going to be in Miami so
you may want to call him and say look
man JB it's my birthday can we do
something send text real quick he's
going to be Jo I'm hanging with a whole
bunch of institutional investors down
there I wonder is he actually in Miami
yeah he's in Miami tonight Miami just so
you know he's in Miami tonight so he
won't know he's in Miami but he's gonna
be there and he's going to be like that
one hey Detroit what's up Detroit how
you doing you're in
[Laughter]
Cincinnati right let's warmer than I
remember Detroit let's do a a couple
other stories here uh let's go to a man
pretending to be a trans wom raped a
female prisoner at Rikers lawsuit says
and that follows with a stat for Gen Z
okay so parents brace for impact you may
want to know what these stats are
because they're trying to get your kids
some people think all right here we go
uh a man pretending to be a transom
woman raped a female prisoner at rer
lawsuit this is from town hall a female
and maate at a women's Correction
Facility in New York in identified as
Rose
doe Roo aando Roso Roso has filed a
lawsuit alleging that a male admid who
claimed to be a transgender raped her
Rose do is suing 20 defendants 20
including the city of New York accusing
the jail staff
of ignoring her warnings about the
transgender inmate according to the
civil suit the transgender inmate moved
into the facility April 2 of
2022 and rape occurred April 7th 3 days
later the male inmate has allegedly star
stared at doe and engaged in
inappropriate behavior in the day before
the rape Rose Do's attorney Nicholas
leakas pointed out that there was simple
ample evidence of the male inmate
potential danger it's ridiculous that
they're allowing this I mean that's
obviously not her name right Roso
they're trying to keep her privacy so
ridiculous yeah potential name including
disciplinary records with complaints of
predatory behavior transgender inmates
in women's prison have raised concerns
about the safety of the female inmates
in the past with instance of sexual
assault and manipulation within the
prison system I just have one quick
comment you it says there was ample
evidence of the male inman's potential
danger uh yeah his
penis I mean it doesn't get more
just like that's a weapon yeah yeah and
you're in a jail with by the way and by
way and what was he arrested for and
mind you guys can New York just when you
thought New York could just not do
anything like more dumb look at what
they're doing this is a New York rer
this is New York bro they're letting men
biological men that have not gone
through their the full transition to be
in prison with women and now it's rape
what are we even talking about Rob what
is that quote is that him saying it yeah
that was him on the uh the phone calls
he's talking to a friend Pat talking how
he don't want no I'm not gay I don't
want no penis quote that's a quote
meaning I don't want to be I don't want
to be in the Men's prison and I don't
want to get attacked and raped myself so
send me some workers workers meaning
prostitutes over here like a whole swap
of workers heterosexuals he wanted to
get into the woman's pres it's called
gaming the system I can identify as a
woman I got I'm a DI a dude with a dick
and now I'm in the female prison and you
know what and this is what happens and
you know what it's by the way they're
not going to change the the the
regulation this is going to keep
happening and where are all you
feminists where are all you women that
were screaming in the streets and
fighting for women everybody's quiet
what H what happened to the feminist
movement where where are you it just
shows where are they data proves
everything right and then the data is
coming out people are getting attacked
and now what do they do with it what do
they do with it what are all the woke
politicians and everybody that are
trying to remember feeling based
decisions have incredible unintended
consequences and they make these
decisions based on feelings he feels
he's a woman he identifies with the
woman let's do over here um Lexi Rose
Crawford the independent if you just Rob
if you'll just do that the independent
Lexi Rose Crawford here is a picture of
a guy who claimed to be a female who
committed a rape in a bathroom I believe
yeah and there it is look at that
yeah hi I'm
transgender yeah by the way he's
claiming to be transmisser is there any
more guy than that and by the way what
you and oh there's my buttons proving
how I feel okay so guess what what did
this guy do is that the guy guy this guy
claimed to be trans and he raped a woman
he went into a bathroom so all you have
to do is grow your hair transgender
woman jailed for rape now sent to a male
prison where he can have his much sex as
he wants like yeah like yeah what are we
like like we talk about this all the
time no transition he just claimed it
and the British Court said well if what
you're okay well then we got to go with
your feeling you're a woman damn it I'm
a woman I'm a woman that's all he did
and the court sent him to the female
prison in three days P he got there on
April 3rd and by April 7th he had
committed not one but two races we
living in bizar World punishment for him
guess what punishment you we are going
to make you a female we are chopping off
your penis you raped a girl cuz you're
trying to pretend that you no I'm dead
serious Lop it off bro you're getting
like enough is enough dude how many more
people have to get raped by the way this
guy God forbid he was in the bathroom
with a young a young kid but people like
no you're you're transphobic no no no
this is happening more more often this
isn't an isolated incident this is
ridiculous we this is on the court
system this is on the systems to be like
uh no this is you're going to a male
prison where I don't care how you
identify you're a biological male you're
going to the male prison look ask you a
question if that happened God forbid I I
don't even like saying this out loud if
one of your kids had to and this
happened I'm and you can't do nothing to
him cuz he's arrested he's going to jail
what would you do I'm going to the
system the people that are making these
decisions I'm going to go to jail
because I'm going to do something crazy
like you're letting people go a man
looking like that going to the bathroom
with my daughter what are we talking
about I don't you're absolutely correct
I'm sorry to interrupt you we're trying
we're trying to move on but I'll make
the point here everyone you're hearing a
lot of outrage on this podcast right now
and there is a lot of outrage but the
outrage needs to start with you and your
heart you need to be at your PTA
meetings you need to be at your
Schoolboard meetings you need to be
speaking up about this and and and just
to to shout back and hit back and push
back in the face of woke that wants to
take the feelings of a person and make
decisions that have the consequence of
endangering your children you've got to
speak up you have to go there The Tide
is turning on Dei The Tide is turning on
this woke stuff now is not the time to
to back down it's election year and now
is the time to be at the city council
meeting be heard be at the Schoolboard
meeting and point out the people cover
them on Facebook talk about what you saw
and be part of the process you can't
don't stop the fight yeah and and this
leads me to the next story which is a
shocking survey PJ media almost
one-third of JZ now identify as gender
queer a recent survey uh reports that
28% by the way now it's up to 20 it used
to be 21% now it's 28% of gen Z adults
18 to 25 in the US identify as lgbtq
which is more than a tenfold increase
compared to older age groups contrast
with 10% of all adults 16% of
Millennials 7% of Gen X and only 4% of
Baby Boomers and the silent generation
the findings align with gallops data
which also shows that gen Z is the most
lgbtq plus identifying generation with
nearly 20% of those ages 19 to 26
identifying as lgbtq lgbtq advoc
advocacy groups such as Human Rights
Campaign emphasize the significance of
lgbtq plus visibility and its potential
influence in elections as thousands of
lgbtq young people become eligible to
vote each day a third a third yeah cuz
you know what you know what they're
showing kids in school Rob I just send
it to Rob Patrick it's a it's a
concerted effort and their plan is
working they want people that have less
kids they want to they want to make
sexualize these children so when people
like that come in the bathroom look at
this is a book called let's talk about
it okay it's available in Middle School
it teaches kids how to masturbate
encourages watching porn and look look
at can you zoom in on the photos please
I know they're blacked out that's in a
middle school they are showing this in a
middle schoool the teens guy to sex
relation with human beings like what are
we talking about they're sexually what
are we teaching kids being a human not
being a boy or girl or male or female
what Agee is this being middle school
middle school is what how old is8 6 sth
8th grade what are we talking about
first of all let me go go go go lower a
little bit let me see what else is it
just guy and girl no that's a guy and a
guy oh my God like what are we talking
about what do we talk about and then and
then they're fighting and then by the
way in these school board meetings these
the the people that are in charge are
fighting so that the kid doesn't have to
tell their parent they don't have to
report the school doesn't have to tell
the parents what they're doing in school
it's a plan and what did you just say 7%
higher it's working Patrick it's working
you know what somebody said in the
comment section they said in one the
pictures look at the guy and the guy
yeah they said P didy got hot for bench
hero oh Jesus best comment by the way
they don't they don't waste any time
they don't waste any time there's a
couple there was an article out last
week I want to say I think I maybe sent
it to you or maybe it was the Instagram
link that gen Z in America is more
likely to be
lgbtq than Republican think about that
what yeah I think I sent you that do you
have that gen Z in America is more
likely to be yeah there it is jenz is
less religious yeah we talked about this
yesterday okay gotcha you're more likely
to be gay in America if you're gen Z
then you are to vote for a republican
think about that that's nuts okay
there's also uh there's an article about
um you're talking about worldwide
because you think gen Z in America we
got think America's just getting gayer
and fatter than ever
it's true but we're not unique you know
around the world so 10 I I guess I
thought it was closer to like 2% 5% I
guess 10% of people identify as lgbtq
this NBC news article if you want to
find global survey 9% of adults identify
as lgbtq you know what the number one
country is for that identifies as
lgbtq huh scroll down you'll see here we
go well who is it keep going down I if
You' find it yeah if you keep going
you'll find it
it go down there's a graph I love graphs
Brazil Brazil 15% there it is Brazil 15%
Spain so you talk about global we talk
about you know uh globalization over
here self identify Spain 14% Switzerland
133% Netherlands
12% Great Britain 12% Sweden 11 Germany
11 Colombia United States 10 and then
you can basically find the if you scroll
down you see what the world averag is
right there the average right there at
9% but hang on go to the
bottom Peru Peru interesting why Peru or
Japan it's interesting but that's all
cultural mean I I would expect maybe
like a Muslim country is going to be
Muslim country where being gay and well
0% there you'll be killed yeah exactly
it's a barrel of laugh so it's like but
it's interesting Peru that's cultural
Machu Picchu you see what I mean yeah
there's not like a there's not like a
not listen here's the deal not that
there's anything wrong with being gay
but 33% of gen z y when the world
averages 9% yeah Jamaica is definitely
low on that too Jamaica they don't
play all right let's go to couple uh uh
you know Steve Harvey and and uh and
Snoop who had something to say so here's
Snoop just recently if you want to pull
this up Rob Snoop Dog Praises Trump
nothing but love and respect a rapper an
advocate for Equity Snoop talk has had a
recent change of tune when it comes to
former president Trump in a new
interview Snoop talk do you have the
video or no Rob can you pull it up to
see if you have the video it's an
article so it was uh given to the Sunday
Times saying Trump's Praises after a
long history of condemning the former
president and his supporters Donald
Trump question mark he ain't done
nothing wrong to me he's done only great
things for me he part in Michael Harris
so I have nothing but love and respect
for Donald Trump Michael Harris and
Associate of Death Row Records
co-founder sh Knight and the founder the
labels parent company Godfather
entertainment was pardoned in 2021 as
one of Trump's final decisions before
leaving office gangster Snoop Dogg was
famously signed by the label only to
leave later in his career he quitted it
in
2022 and uh Harris was imprisoned on
charges of conspiracy and attempt to
murder for overd those three decade
Snoop Dog pra Trump at the time of his
Comm commutation of Harris by the way
didn't he end up buying Death Row
Records ended up buying Death Row Record
and then at the same time Steve Harvey
comes out and says the following I don't
know if you have this clip or not Rob if
you if you don't have it uh uh all good
if you do have it just play it how long
ago is this by the way this clip can you
see how long what this clip was so this
is pre 2016 this is uh seven years ago
this pre when he ran yes when Steve
Harvey so we don't need to play this
clip but this was when he said this but
for Snoop to say that how do what do you
think what do you think's going on for
Snoop to and by the way how many
followers does Snoop have on Instagram I
know it's a big number that is huge um
let me see this here Snoop on Insta must
have uh 20 85 million followers on inst
85 million followers on Instagram how
much of an impact does this have for
Snoop to say this it's it's it's huge
and this is random that you're talking
about this it's absolutely huge just
like when the Biden grabbed what's her
face cardi B remember those interviews
and she's like Mr Biden like you
whatever and then and then she flipped
once now a couple months ago was atam
she's like the taxes and the war she's
losing her mind but that's huge the
block that he represents is huge it's
Millions it's millions of people do you
think it's that big of a deal I you know
I I was talking to a couple guys who are
in the sports and entertainment business
and we had a call two days ago and uh we
had a call
yesterday and I brought the story up and
you know the the conversation was
about hey you know uh uh uh what can
African-American an do because they've
been owned by the left the Democrats to
vote you know God knows what percentage
ever since 1964 Barry Goldwater and all
the stuff in 1960 it was only
64% of African-Americans voting almost
every African-American friend I had in
the military when I would meet their mom
or grandma they were all Bible
God-fearing conservatives who talked to
me like I'm their kid and we were afraid
of them do you know what I'm saying
they're like hey hey you know and it was
almost like a super super you know
faithful you know not what you're seeing
today so I think deep down inside in The
Roots I think the African-American
Community they're very much a
God-fearing you know again Generations
things have changed today on what it is
uh but for me for Snoop to do this you
think other people are sitting there
saying wow why would Snoop say something
like this about Trump maybe he's right
cuz he's he he's like in The Godfather
community of rappers right would you be
would you consider him as one of the OG
OG guys 100% 100% rap's not my thing but
looking at a case study of the music he
is one of the Mount Rushmore of the of
the genre and of music business yeah I
think I think influence wise he is as a
rapper I don't know if they would put
him on a mount rushar I think it's
different names would be there but
you're right influence wise for sure
he's generational on what he's been
through and and some of the you know
songs that he's made and Ice Cube Ice
Cube is is in the same what do you mean
big deal I I think uh look one thing
I've learned about
snoop snoop is for sale man I thinking
is just about the this has nothing to do
with politics okay a month ago we
covered a story about smooth Snoop quit
smoking oh and but he was pitching a
thanks Tom a month ago we covered this
whole thing and we're like and I said
Point Blank I go this is I know
you called it I go I said this this dude
made his entire brand about smoking and
now he came out and he said he stopped
smoking I gave up smoke and what was he
doing it was a pitch commercial for a
smokeless Grill yeah which was dog
you're willing to throw your whole brand
in the garbage to basically make a
couple bucks doing a burger flipping
Grill stop it it's more than a couple
bucks but this is a completely different
situation he will sell out for the money
but but in this case listen things have
to be things have to be getting so bad
like for you monetarily he lives in
California for you to say I'm going for
Trump and guys let's not forget this is
the season this is the year and I don't
know if you're going to talk about it
pat the Trav the the Taylor Swift
remember with the AI and Taylor Swift
and Travis Kelce let's not listen I
could genuinely care less about either
one of them but let's be honest but by
the way let me read that story and let's
go into it let's wrap up with this we'll
make that The Last Story Taylor Swift
could sway 2024 election outcome new
poll finds a poll conducted by Redfield
and Wilton strategies for Newsweek
reveals that Taylor Swift's endorsement
could sway the votes of a significant
portion of
America bless you bless you see he's
allergic to significant portion
of Americans with 18% saying they're
more likely to support a candidate
endorsed by the pop star this influence
is particularly pronounced amongst
voters under 35 and with the addition of
41 million gen ZZ voters in this
election her impact is expected to be
significant however 177% of respondents
stated that they would be less likely to
vote for a candidate backed by Swift
potentially posing a challenge for
Democrat Joe Biden about 55% of those
pulled ped claim to be neutral and not
swayed either way by her endorsement
Vinnie thoughts on this well okay and
and I I'll I'll say it again I can
literally genuinely care less about her
or Travis Kelce in their obviously stag
relationship but it's to push agendas
okay he's pushing an experimental potion
on the youth and Taylor is telling her
brainwash swifties to vote for the
corrupt Democrat Party that's when I
have a problem people like oh you're
just hating on her no no I can care less
God bless her do your own thing but
besides all the tactics that the left
uses to cheat including this open border
with the illegals she she's another
weapon in their Arsenal cuz by the way
let's not forget who she is Rob she
hasn't said it yet but 2020 cuz it's
coming for her I sent you this on um in
slack this is what she said about Trump
after stoking the fires of white
supremacy and racism your entire
presidency you have the nerve to Fain
moral superiority before threatening
violence when the Looting starts the
shooting starts we will vote you out in
November she is such an influential per
guys and you just said it a fifth of the
voters are going to go for it and that
poll was conducted by uh Redfield and
Wilton strategies that 18% are likely to
vote for her if she opens her mouth and
says it and then by the way guess who
owns her in 2019 Rob I sent you this
clip this is by the way she calls out
George Soros for buying all of her music
do you watch show this
Rob I had the chance to purchase my
music outright my entire catalog was
sold to scooter bronze Ithaca Holdings
in a deal that I'm told was funded by
the Soros family 23 capital and the
Carlile group oh so she admit she admits
sorus is one of the owners all right
then the headlines in the mainstream
media are focusing on her and Travis and
now the headlines are stating that she
can sway an election this is another way
guys George Soros that just decrepit
evil dude he has his hands in everything
with election with paying for these
pales the pro Palestine the protest and
everything this guy is embedded in our
stuff and they're going to use her it's
coming she's going to say Trump is the
racist guy again and those people vote
exactly what she says and she is going
to make a change Tom so the reason you
don't see more politicians looking for
um full loud vocal um endorsements from
celebrities is because celebrities the
analysis of celebrity endorsements shows
that there is a not equal but there is
an opposite side that actually hurts you
that for every celebrity you have you've
got people that actually pull back or
maybe don't agree or offended with that
Obama's campaign figured out and they
did it right you can read about David
axide and a guy named David POF that did
it they realized that you trust
me you trust Adam you trust rob you
trust Pat your circle of friends so in
social media when the Obama campaign
influenced influencers not Mega
influencers just to get the circle of us
talking talking that moves voters Hearts
because we start talking about our
issues even if we're vacuous 15-year-old
girls with no brain we talk about what
few and little tiny issues matter to us
and we don't worry about taxes don't
understand that whereas large celebrity
endorsements can help but there's
usually an equal not equal and opposite
relation reaction like physics but
there's usually now a negative side of
it that goes along with that too and
celebrities have a incredible habit of
ending up on the pages of tabloids that
you don't want to be associated with
because opposition research and
opposition ads now are going to use that
so you know Taylor Swift has a lot of
power and a lot of influence and do I
think she can move some of this uh yeah
I do but do I think she's going to move
the election no because if she could do
that she'd have $3 billion in her pocket
and that that would be she's on the aist
tours made billion Tom she is by the way
and what's his name Shannon sharp just
had oo and they were like by the way she
doesn't she made that money she made
that no I understand that but they're
look who's behind her Tom and like it's
all they prop she by the way she's
always been famous have you noticed in
this past year two years she has
skyrocketed to where people are like
dude Beyonce Shannon sharp was like
Beyonce doesn't move the needle like
Taylor Swift this is a this is a
purposeful fake relationship if you
don't see what's happening dude think
about it the her boyfriend is pushing
vaccines and she's million you know what
she's going to say 20 million she's
basically brought how many viewers to
the NFL and it's only a matter of give
it a month give it two months when when
the election is is going full gear Trump
is racist he's a white supremist if you
love me I'm Taylor Swift don't vote for
that guy vote for whoever the left has
and that's it Super Bowl in two weeks
and who's playing in the Super Bowl
Kansas City yeah and guess what I
guarantee by way the when the Kansas
City Chiefs win and the confetti coming
they're going to kiss he's probably
going to get his ninth booster they're
going to get all kiss they'll be broken
up in a year mark my words one year
they'll be done but that's neither here
nor he was smart he have a baby with her
I I would there's an influence but it's
it's not what everybody thinks and
that's why
celebrities that's why you don't have
celebrities getting phone calls like
Carri Lake did otherwise they would be
like hey Pat 3 billion
there's people you see you you know what
I mean who that V tweeted something
yesterday about this fake relationship
you saw that saw that it's funny it's
it's obvious I saw that I mean look
we're going to see every uh four years
everybody wants the endorsement of a
person to say oh if we get Oprah
Winfrey's endorsement oh if we get this
remember the Rock and even they wanted
Michael Jordan's inv remember in the
Last Dance Barack Obama talked about how
disappointed he was with Michael and
Michael wouldn't give endorsement
Michael's like no I'm good man I'm not
his mom's like you may want to consider
showing up to this you know campaign for
this such and such no I'm not going to
be there ma you're not going to show up
I think you ought to I'm not showing up
I was very disappointed when Michael
didn't show up to that and we had we
talked about it you know this what
Barack Obama was talking about you know
Tom Tom makes a very good point if I
also know you're endorsed by certain
candidate or certain celebrity it may
also be a turnoff to me and it may
backfire but we'll see I think think a
lot of people are saying she's going to
do something like that I think it's uh U
no surprise when she does but we'll see
what happened there by the way uh
tomorrow Tom and I will be sitting down
Tom Rob is that confirmed for
tomorrow uh that would be
Thursday isn't there something today
flying out to tomorrow is Brian Garcia
and then Thursday is Trevor Bower okay
got it Thursday Trevor bow and then
tomorrow's Ryan Garcia the boxer yes sir
okay I'm going to have an interesting
conversation with him I think this the
first first sit down he's doing since
some of the challenges
with since some of the challenges with
um uh uh uh De La Hoya Floyd Mayweather
bunch of different things well I have
the conversation uh he reached out and
I'm looking forward to seeing this
should be a very very interesting
conversation with Ryan Garcia the boxing
world is a whole different thing that's
going on this guy's a a young
goodlooking millions of followers when
he fights people want to show up he's
got a DI hard loyal follow him we'll
have a good conversation with him and
Trevor Bower I think the MLB is making a
mistake not offering him a contract I
really want to get to the bottom of this
why is somebody who's a former siong
winner who's young in his 30s 32 32 33
years old how is this guy not getting a
contract today because what because of a
girl accusing him of something we'll sit
down and have a conversation I think
this is his first sit down he's doing
long form to openly talk about what
happened with him and how to H his
baseball career and we'll see how the
MLB react ACC to this take care
everybody we'll see you guys soon
bye-bye